I remember we had um a baseball field we
played on and I was on a really rotgut
team called the Cubs and a couple
jerseys they'd they accidentally wrote
clubs on it and it just so about six of
the guys on our team or on the Cubs that
play Ville Cubs and we had about three
or four guys on the play Ville clubs and
we would play on a field out there on
the edge of town off of highway 190 that
had a slant it had a gradient they just
I don't know if you know there had been
like uh they might have been having
gravity issues or something or I'm not
sure this might have been during a
sinkhole flare up I'm not sure because
that sinkholes those things do when the
when that when Mother Earth has had too
much to eat and net [__] belches
somebody's losing a [__] half a
parking lot full of Honda Civics or
something you know they've you know she
ain't afraid to digest anything it could
be somebody hitchhiking you know
somebody driving a Dodge Ram everybody
is going straight into the Earth's core
um but we played softball on a on this
field not softball we it was regular
ball baseball and man I wouldn't go to
baseball man I
I remember asking the coach one time if
we could put tape on the ball like rook
you know like duct tape so that they
wouldn't come in it wouldn't hit you
know it wouldn't be as hard when it hit
the glove so most of baseball was me
hiding kind of whenever the good batters
would get up because I'm a daydreamer I
don't need a bed I don't need a pillow
- you know to really create that
ambience I'm that sir I got that
Spielberg in me I got that cerebral
Spielberg you know I got this [__] is
it's going in my head and so baseball
and a date you can't daydream and do
baseball you can't you cannot do it
because you're out there and next thing
you know you'll be [__] that ball
comes zinging at you you'll lose an ox
it you know it'll you'll pop your
occipital it hit you and I you one of
y'all one of your eyeballs roll right
out your mouth like you're a Halloween
game show that [__] can get tricky but
we played on a field when I was on the
Cubs clubs that was at a slant and dude
you would hit a grounder towards first
base and by the time it got to like the
outfield it was oh it was on it was
along the third-base line it was just
every ball so the best player was out
there on third base or in the left field
and I didn't I wasn't good at it man cuz
I would forget we were playing I forget
I was playing you die Bri I'll be out
there way out in right field picking
stuff and eating it or trying stuff I
mean I wouldn't need I would not eat
everything that I picked that wasn't I
wasn't that boy you know you always had
that one creepy boy just anything he
find he just slid it into his mouth and
it could be anything it's dude you put a
damn snake in his mouth you know some of
these guys they'll babysit a damn you
finally get their jaws open and they're
in there you know they're having you
know a couple little oysters or and
they're doing conjugal visits and stuff
some people will put anything under
their tongue Oh
but that field man it was so hard
because if a ball went into the outfield
and you got it you had to run you had to
run uphill it was very
I mean it was like a damn decathlon just
trying to get the ball in and sometimes
you would throw it and it would come
right back down the hill at two you're
like gee well and then at the far left
field it went sloped that way it sloped
out there one guy hit it this one fella
Mikey Donnell war and he was my god this
guy he was um I mean he must have came
out of the womb with a uh you know he
must have came out of the womb with a
damn with capability and capability is
when you just when you're not you know
when you just when you can do something
have you ever done anything
well that's capability right there and
this boy just had all the athletic
capability and he would hit that ball
and we went to get it and went over the
deep off the edge deep field and dude it
took you sometimes I remember getting a
ball and coming up the hill off the deep
end and by the time I got up there the
game had been over for about 40 minutes
everybody's just knuckle deep eating
snow cones and some of the parents are
over there you know you know complaining
about their spouses or whatever some of
this one lady would cry every time we
won like [__] you're not even gonna
have a kid on the team okay you just out
here lurk and I said list lady would
creep us out dude she'd be crying
somebody would hit a damn double and she
would start crying I'm like jeepers and
she had a Don Mattingly tattoo on her
[__] on her ribs but she was
beautiful though I will say that she had
a certain beauty about her you know
there's something there's something very
American about it when somebody hits a
damn double you know and a lady starts
crying just a few feet away there's
something
hell I don't even know it's almost like
it's like that movie uh it's the way I
feel when I'm when I watch that movie
Cinderella man my heaven
I think [__] get me bro Cinderella
man what's going on good to see you
happy November 18 and it is the year
2019 to zero one nine and we are living
it we are living through time I was
thinking about that this weekend how
time is just such a it won't you can't
stop it I mean you just on it's just a
it's kind of like the it's the LeBron
James of mediums this [__] is going and
sometimes I realize I'm like hey time
time time you know I'm over here you
know hold it up but timing [__] with
you boy timing [__] with you you
little [__] out here on that
lopsided field get your [__] together I
can't believe our town would do all of
that just really and they had regular
fields I think they had a couple parents
out there like seeing the children
struggle and seeing you'd have some kids
do they play baseball so much they'd
have a dam they would grow in the
genetic leave and one of their legs
almost had a little bit more reach on it
they beam a little bit more right legged
or you'd see some of the coaches out
there would measure that right leg on
you during practices and stuff because
see who would be able to get the best
angles based on the field and that was
it's weird when carpentry kind of comes
into a baseball you know when somebody
when you got a damn subcontractor out
there playing on the you know as the
third-base coach it just gets a little
kind of obtuse thanks for watching that
video right there that was a beautiful
little segment I think
but of course I'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you can check on this video or on
this video that's two different options
and you can also subscribe to the
channel check on a new video subscribe
to the channel check subscribe check
check Joseph's car Scott